-We are joined right now
by a legendary chef.
He's an Emmy and James Beard
Award winner
and the founder of
the Jacques Pépin Foundation.
Everyone please welcome
Chef Jacques Pépin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you. Come on. I love you!
Welcome back to the show.
I love you.
Tomorrow is Thanksgiving, and I
was just wondering if you could
show me how to properly carve
a turkey because I am a moron.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
-I'll show you how to carve it.
Properly? I don't know.
-Okay, alright.
But let's see the way
Jacques Pépin does it.
-To start with,
when you roast it like this,
you remove the wishbone.
You know, that triangle here?
-Oh, okay.
-It's in the way to carve,
so you remove it.
See, they remove it
before cooking. It's here.
And here, you've got to pull on
the other side.
-Let's make a wish.
[ Audience ohs ]
Wow! What happened?
We both got our wishes
came true. Yeah!
That was cool.
That's so cool. Look at this.
That just popped off equally.
Oh, my gosh. I'm saving this.
Okay, cool.
-So, anyway, so here like this,
you can do that.
So here, now you can cut
this way directly.
And then you go right
down into slice.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Now, see, this is --
I can't do this.
-Of course you can.
You're going to do
the other side.
-Oh, oh, my gosh.
I actually am going to do this.
-Yeah, do this side here.
Or you can do it maybe bigger.
So, you cut it this way.
-Yep. Cut it that way.
Watch out, be careful,
I'm not -- around me.
-Lower.
-Lower?
-Yeah, that's it.
-Right under the wishbone thing?
-Yes.
-Go across.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, beautiful.
-Wow, that felt good.
-That's how you start slicing.
-And then slice it like this?
-Yes. Now you go -- Because now
it stops right there.
-Oh, yeah.
-Whoa, you're good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this.
Whoa, look at this!
-Perfect.
-Are you kidding me?
I'm gonna stop here
just 'cause it looks so good.
-Yeah, that's perfect.
Then we remove the dark meat,
you know?
Dark meat. I use my hand.
It's easier.
-Yeah. Of course, you just get
right in there
and remove it with your hand.
-And you take the drumstick
and you cut it in half.
And then, now we cut that
in two pieces.
Make sure to use the skin
because the skin is very good.
-The skin is the best.
-Do you want to taste it?
-I do. I would love to taste it.
Sure.
Oh, my gosh.
I love just doing
anything with you.
Yeah, that was amazing.
I wanted to ask you something.
My favorite part is the next
day, or maybe even later
that night when you make
a turkey sandwich.
-Oh, yes.
[ Cheers ]
-You know what I'm saying?
-I love turkey sandwich.
-You do?
I was thinking what we could do
is maybe make a sandwich
and give Questlove --
You can be our taste tester.
-Okay.
-And then he can say who made
the better Thanksgiving
sandwich.
You want to have a competition?
-Fine.
-You ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, before we start,
we need Quest to put on
the dome of silence
so he won't know
who made which --
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so, can you --
You can't see, right?
Okay, perfect.
Ready to make this sandwich?
He can't hear anything either.
-I can take any bread I want?
Here, okay, here.
-You're doing that bread?
-Yes. I have some stuff
underneath here.
-You have a secret ingredient?
-Yeah, I have some sriracha,
some hot sauce.
-Sriracha?
-Yes.
-Alright.
-You want some of it?
-No.
-Oh, good.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I'm going stuffing
all the way.
I really think stuffing
is a big hit this year.
-Some mustard here.
-Mustard? Okay.
Sriracha and mustard.
I'm just going stuffing.
This is going to be real dry
though, right?
-I have some olive oil.
-What are you doing?
Oh, olive oil.
Oh, yeah, I might use some of
that olive oil.
-I have some lettuce too.
-Lettuce is delicious,
but, you know.
-Want some lettuce?
-No.
Yeah, it looks nice, right?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, lettuce is good.
I'll put one -- two things of
lettuce on there.
Ooh, look at that.
It's actually gonna be good.
I'm going to do a little gravy
on mine.
Should I put it on the bread
so the breads --
kind of sops it up a little bit?
[ Laughter ]
-Can I have some gravy too?
-Yeah, I guess so.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you can have some gravy.
Alright, so you're putting gravy
too.
How is Questlove drumming
while not seeing or hearing?
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Turkey right here.
And then --
-You took the piece I wanted.
-I know I did, right?
[ Laughter ]
I took the good one, right?
I carved that side.
-No, no, I'm doing
only the dark meat.
-I think Quest would think --
-I like the dark meat.
-What is this? What's that?
-Oh, this is the gratin
that my mother used to do.
In France, we never do --
we never do sweet pumpkin.
The pumpkin is done with
cream and cheese.
You want to taste it?
-Yeah, I do want to taste it,
to just check it out.
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
-Want to put it
in your sandwich?
-Yeah, that's --
I want that recipe.
The gratin.
Ooh, Jacques Pépin gratin.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, gonna put
a little cranberry.
Just a little --
just a little bit.
Just enough. Just enough.
And then look at this.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Wow.
That's sugar, though.
-Oh, wait, it's not sugar,
is it?
[ Laughter ]
You got me, buddy. Oh, my gosh.
Alright.
Wait, that's all I'm gonna make.
I'm gonna go -- That's it.
That's simple.
Is that enough?
[ Cheers ]
Alright, audience
seems to like --
-Here is mine.
-Oh, my goodness.
If I beat Jacques Pépin at
a sandwich making contest, yes!
Whoo! I'm excited.
-Can I put that --
[ Laughter ]
-No, whoa, where'd you get that?
-Right there.
-Oh, I love you.
Happy Thanksgiving.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, Tariq,
can you let him know?
-Take -- Take --
It's time to take the --
-Stop the song.
-Oh, yeah.
Wait. Oh, yeah.
Alright.
-I'm ready?
-Yeah.
-Quest.
-Here, I'll take it.
-[ French accent ] We have
two turkey sandwiches here.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-One is made by Jacques Pépin.
[ Normal voice ]
Alright, so take a bite and
let's see what you think.
-Alright.
-Yep. Start with that one.
Okay, alright.
-Hm.
-Okay.
-Turkey's great.
-Yep, it is good.
Yeah, great. He said "great."
[ Laughter ]
-Someone should hold the tray
for him.
-Yeah, no, this is getting good.
-He needs two hands
for that one.
-Ooh, ooh.
[ Laughter ]
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-There's a lot going on with
this one.
[ Laughter ]
-Not going down. Not going down.
-Alright. I'll say this much.
Because he's a better cook
than I am,
I would have probably made
this sandwich.
So, this is more me,
but this one actually tastes
a little better.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wait. Who won?
-You guessed correctly.
That's Jacques's.
That's mine. That's mine.
That's correct.
That's exactly the right choice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're the champ. Jacques Pépin!
Go to jp.foundation to learn
more about Jacques's
video series "Cook with Jacques
and Friends."
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.